let's do some audience questions first
one for this week David do you think
that things people have choice or
control over should be included as
protected classes for example religion
pregnancy status veteran status this is
really really complex okay and there are
people who say that when we talk about
protected classes one logical way to
divide them would be sort of immutable
characteristics and things that you
choose characteristics that you choose
so the for example you don't choose your
race so race should absolutely be a
protected class but you do choose your
religion so maybe religion should not be
a protected class but the problem with
that is that you very quickly do get to
things like pregnancy status and veteran
status and by and large there is
consensus I would argue although I don't
have polling on this but I think that we
probably have consensus in the United
States that you shouldn't be allowed to
discriminate against people because they
are pregnant because even if it is a
choice to become pregnant for the most
part although there are unintended
pregnancies all the time that pregnancy
is how the species Homo sapiens persists
and that thus discriminating against
people on the basis of that would would
just sort of not be right veteran status
we don't have a draft in the United
States because we have a volunteer army
that is big enough although they have
their fair share of recruiting problems
we have a volunteer army and we don't
want to allow individuals to be
penalized for choosing to join the
military which millions and millions and
millions of Americans don't want to do
and don't have to do because they are
doing that so I actually think there's a
lot to not discriminating on the basis
of immutable characteristics but I don't
know that anything you choose should
allow for discrimination I I would I
would be be a little bit skittish about
going that far yeah it's tough because
you have to draw a line at some point
right not everything can be a protected
class and you know we have to draw
things that I think we have control over
things that we choose because that seems
like it's the clearest point to draw
that line you'd like me to say yeah I do
yeah we talked about you know recently
with the Sarah Huckabee stand her story
her getting kicked out of a restaurant
whether or not it's okay for a
restaurant or a place of employment or
place of business to kick someone out on
the basis of you know political
affiliation yeah whether or not they
support the president whether they work
for the president and I think that my
conclusion on that is that they should
have that right if it was over something
like race or something immutable I don't
think they should be able to okay I
agree with your examples but that
doesn't necessarily simplify the problem
of for example pregnancy status do you
think you should be able to discriminate
against someone either in terms of
employment or service at a business on
the basis of them being pregnant well
the issue with pregnancy status and
veteran status is that it those are
usually choices but not in every case
like you may not have chosen to have the
child in one way or another you ended up
with it or veteran status I mean we
don't have a draft anymore but we
certainly did during the World War 2 era
so that was we're still alive in Vietnam
- you know some people are in their 70s
or 80s or served in Vietnam oh that's a
fair point you know so how would how
would we be able to decide okay this
person decided to be a member of the US
military this person did not decide to
be a member of the US military you know
we would have to come up with some sort
of paperwork or something like that it's
not it's not easy to do the the
pregnancy one has another angle which is
that right now it's a women who get
pregnant at some point maybe that
changes you know we've read about
interesting science going on which might
allow men to become pregnant at some
point but right now de-facto if you
allow discrimination on the basis of
pregnancy it is a form of discrimination
that only would apply to women because
only women can get pregnant at this
point of time in time so I think that
that is that is actually hugely
problematic let's take a step back from
this for a second to think about what
what are we really saying here when we
talk about protected classes what we're
saying is in my view that in society
there would be a type of classification
there are certain types of
classifications which by discriminating
against them we are saying
we are okay with a certain type of
society and by saying you can't not
serve people on the basis of race what
we are saying is that that would be a
type of classification that would be so
toxic and damaging to society that we
are going to say it is against the law
and that's where I think that we
distinguish some of these choice ones
from other ones so for example political
affiliation or sports affiliation a bar
can say if it's a Red Sox bar they can
say you can't come in here with Yankees
hats and if you're an over Yankee
supporter we're not gonna allow you in
and it could be because they found that
the number of fights goes down
drastically when you do that or whatever
that's very different than someone who
is for example a veteran or is pregnant
and saying you are going to refuse
service to them I think that there is
absolutely a difference yeah I mean
under that model you would have to make
it come down to case-by-case basis right
whereas if you say that choices you can
discriminate on based on but something
inherent like your race or color or
creed or any of that stuff you can't
that's a little bit more clear-cut it's
a little bit more of an easy principle
to abide by it sounds like it but let me
give you an example that would very
quickly complicate it not everybody
agrees as to whether sexual orientation
is a choice I believe that it is not
really yeah I believe the science pretty
clear you say it's not a traumatically
it's not a choice oh boy
all of a sudden I thought we had some
confusion there will be people who
disagree about what is a choice even
with religion there are people who say
you can leave a religion you can convert
but colloquially speaking you're born
into a religion most people are simply
born into the religion of their parents
and even though they can leave there are
individuals who would say religion is
not really a choice and thus it should
be protected and there's also another
reason which is that if you have
religious freedom on the basis of the
Constitution and the Bill of Rights that
actually supersedes non-discrimination
laws and that's another issue that that
we may have to contend with on this that
is a good point there but I think you
in the United States have the choice to
relieve your religion which there could
be some coercion involved by members of
your church or mosque or whatever it is
that should not be allowed and I think
you would have to pursue anyone who's
doing that when it comes to sexual
orientation I think you can pretty
adequately argue that it is not a choice
and thus this problem wouldn't arise
from I believe you can and there are
millions of people who disagree and
believe that that it is a choice and I
guess my question is not so much about
debating whether it is or isn't a choice
I believe it's not but more about how do
you adjudicate what is or is not a
choice when you know that there will be
disagreement